Aphrodite, the goddess of love, is looking down on earth one day. Spots a mortal woman named Psyche, who is so beautiful Aphrodite is jealous. Sends her son Cupid down to earth to destroy her.
爱神阿佛洛狄忒有一天俯视人间，看到了一个名叫普赛克的凡间女子，她美若天仙，阿佛洛狄忒心生嫉妒，便派遣自己的儿子丘比特下凡去毁掉她。
Cupid sees Psyche. Naturally falls in love with the woman his mother hates most in the world. Only surprise about that part of the story is they're not all Jews.
丘比特见到了普赛克，自然而然地爱上了这个母亲在世上最痛恨的女人。关于这个故事，唯一让人吃惊的是他们并非全是犹太人。
[LAUGHTER}
（笑声）
Cupid marries Psyche. But he doesn't want Psyche to know that he's a god. He thinks it'll ruin things. She won't love him for who he is in his heart. She'll just love him because he's famous and powerful.
丘比特娶了普赛克，但他不想让普赛克知道自己是神。他认为这会毁了一切。她不会因为他的内心而爱他，只会因为他有名望、有权势才爱他。
So he makes her promise to never look at him. They have this passionate love that takes place entirely in the dark. But her girlfriends talk to her behind his back. They tell her that if he never wants her to see him, it must be because he has something to hide, must be a monster.
于是，他让她发誓永远不要看他。他们拥有一种完全在黑暗中进行的炽热爱情。但她的朋友们在背后挑拨，告诉她如果他不让她看他，那一定是因为他有什么隐情，他一定是个怪物。
So she comes to him at night while he's sleeping, with a lit candelabra. And she sees him there. He's naked. He's perfect. He has wings. He's beautiful.
于是，在一个夜晚，趁他熟睡时，她拿着点燃的烛台走到他身边。她看到了他。他赤身裸体。他完美无瑕。他长着翅膀。他美极了。
And she's just about to go when some wax from one of the candles falls on him, and he wakes with a start. And their eyes meet. He sees that she's betrayed him. She broke her promise. She doubted his love. She wanted to see. And the gods punish her.
正当她准备离开时，一滴蜡油落在他的身上，他惊醒过来。两人四目相对。他看出她背叛了他。她违背了誓言。她怀疑了他的爱。她想要窥探。众神惩罚了她。
This, I say to you as somebody who works in a medium, radio, where you never see anything-- this is what seeing is all about. Right there. We do not listen to our hearts. We doubt, and then we want to look.
作为一名在广播这种永远看不见任何东西的媒介工作的人，我想对你们说——这就是“看”的真谛所在。就在那一刻。我们没有倾听自己的内心。我们产生了怀疑，于是想要一探究竟。
And seeing is about something else. It's about power. I checked with an actual humanities professor, and this is what he told me. Richard Klein teaches at Cornell.
而“看”还关乎别的东西。它关乎权力。我向一位真正的人文学教授求证过，他是这么告诉我的。理查德·克莱因在康奈尔大学任教。
The power of the look to dominate and even destroy is a very old story in human history, and may have biological origins. When a dog, for example, looks directly in the eye of another animal or human, as if to stare it down, that's a certain sign of hostile feelings, a sort of challenge, a prelude to aggression.
“注视”所具有的支配甚至毁灭的力量在人类历史上是一个非常古老的故事，可能有着生物学起源。例如，当一只狗直视另一只动物或人类的眼睛时，仿佛是在通过瞪视压倒对方，这是一种敌意的明确信号，是一种挑战，是攻击的前奏。
It's an ancient rule, he says. It's why slaves don't look in the eyes of their masters. It's why you don't meet the eyes of a king while you bow in his presence. It's why parts of British royalty, even today, prefer not to be seen in public, not to be photographed, even after Princess Diana became the most photographed woman in the world.
他说，这是一条古老的准则。这就是为什么奴隶不敢直视主人的眼睛，这就是为什么你在国王面前鞠躬时不能与他目光交接。这也是为什么即使在今天，英国王室的某些成员也宁愿不在公共场合露面，不被拍照，即便戴安娜王妃已经成了世界上被拍摄次数最多的女性。
And I mean, the monarchy itself, Queen Elizabeth in particular, has long sort of felt that it was, on the contrary, more sort of appropriate to the monarchy, and perhaps even necessary to its survival, that it appear less in public. I think that's one of the reasons why they were so alarmed by Diana. I mean, de Gaulle, in France, believed powerfully that leaders should be little seen and rarely heard, that the power sort of comes from the invisibility.
我的意思是，君主制本身，特别是伊丽莎白女王，长期以来一直认为，相反，君主制更适合——或许甚至是维持其生存所必需的——少在公共场合露面。我认为这就是他们对戴安娜感到如此惊恐的原因之一。我的意思是，法国的戴高乐非常坚定地认为，领导人应该少露面、少被听到，那种权力似乎源于隐形。
I've been thinking a lot lately about why somebody would pay $30 to come to a theater and see a show that you can get for free on the radio. And I think that this is the very reason. Right here, on the radio, invisible, we are just too powerful. Seeing us, seeing anybody that you hear on the radio, it makes them human-size-- which seems like a healthy thing, actually.
最近我一直在思考，为什么有人会花30美元走进剧场去看一场你在广播里就能免费听到的节目。我想这正是原因所在。在广播里，通过隐形，我们实在是太强大了。看到我们，看到任何你在广播里听到的人，会将他们还原为人类的大小——这其实看起来是一件健康的事情。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, today bringing you a co-production with WNYC in New York, a live show from Town Hall in New York City.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台（PRI）的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，今天为您带来的是与纽约WNYC联合制作的节目，一场在纽约市政厅举办的现场演出。
Today on our program, as hundreds of people watch us do this show, our theme is What Are You Lookin' At? Stories of what it means to be seen and to see. Act One, American Goth, the story of one woman's ongoing quest to look meaner. Act Two, Lifesavers, the story of a teenage girl who would hit you if you looked at her the wrong way, and what happened when suddenly hundreds of people were looking at her, all at once. Act Three, Climb Every Mountain. Die-hard New Yorker David Rakoff heads off to a land of incomprehensible people who, he worries, are always noticing how different he is, a land called New Hampshire.
今天在我们的节目中，当数百名观众注视着我们录制这档节目时，我们的主题是“你在看什么？”关于被注视和注视的意义的故事。第一幕，“美国哥特式”，讲述了一个女人不断寻求让自己看起来更凶狠的故事。第二幕，“救生员”，讲述了一个十几岁的女孩，如果别人以不当的方式看她，她就会打人，而当数百人突然同时注视她时，发生了什么。第三幕，“攀登每一座山”。死忠的纽约客大卫·拉科夫前往一片难以理解的土地，他担心那里的人总是注意到他的格格不入，那片土地叫新罕布什尔。
Onstage also here at Town Hall, They Might Be Giants and the This American Life Orchestra. Stay with us.
同样在市政厅舞台上的还有“他们可能是巨人”（They Might Be Giants）乐队和《美国生活》管弦乐团。请继续收听。
Act One, American Goth.
第一幕，“美国哥特式”。
There are the people who take hours to get dressed, who dress primarily to be seen, and then there are the rest of us. Sometimes someone tries to make the jump from that second group into the first group. Please welcome writer Sarah Vowell.
有些人花几个小时打扮，主要是为了被别人看，然后是像我们这样的普通人。有时，有人试图从后一组跨越到前一组。欢迎作家莎拉·沃威尔。
I'm sitting at my desk quietly minding my own, as they say in the rap songs, when my torturer darkens the doorway. She drags me into a cramped bathroom, shoves my head under a faucet, shines a blinding light in my eyes, cinches my neck in plastic sheeting, and comes at me with scissors. She douses me with chemicals and makes me sit there, dehydrating under the plastic, while the acid stings my flesh.
正如说唱歌曲里所说的，我正静静地坐在桌边忙自己的事，这时我的“折磨者”遮住了门口。她把我拖进狭窄的洗手间，把我的头塞到水龙头下，用刺眼的灯光照着我的眼睛，用塑料布勒住我的脖子，然后挥舞着剪刀朝我走来。她用化学药剂浇透我的头，让我坐在那儿，在塑料布下脱水，酸性物质刺痛着我的皮肤。
And so when I look up from my desk and see her standing there with the scissors, I shudder. "Hi, Mom," I say. "Guess you think I need a haircut."
所以，当我从桌子抬头看到她拿着剪刀站在那儿时，我战栗了。“嗨，妈，”我说，“猜你觉得我该剪头发了。”
My mother had been a hairdresser before my twin sister Amy and I were born. More precisely, she was a hairdresser in Oklahoma in the 1960s-- the beehive's golden age. Since she gave up her career to take care of us, all that energy that used to go into whipping hundreds of heads into an architectural frenzy was focused on the two of us. And since we were as bald as pharaohs, she killed time while our hair was growing in by Scotch-taping bows to our newborn noggins.
在我双胞胎妹妹艾米和我出生前，我母亲曾是一位理发师。准确地说，她是20世纪60年代俄克拉荷马州的一名理发师——蜂窝发型的黄金时代。自从她放弃事业照顾我们后，她曾经用来将数百个头颅打造成建筑奇观的所有精力，都集中在我们俩身上了。而由于我们当时像法老一样光头，她在我们头发长出来之前就用透明胶带把蝴蝶结粘在我们新生儿的脑袋上打发时间。
Her ardor for our appearance increased as we got older, and her attentions never stopped at the neck. There were clothes. There were shoes. Accessories.
随着我们长大，她对我们外表的狂热程度与日俱增，而且她的关照从未止步于脖子。有衣服。有鞋子。配饰。
Amy liked to think about such things, shop for such things. Unlike me, my sister did not threaten to call Amnesty International every time Mom wanted to give her a home perm. I was a bit of an embarrassment to my mother-- all scuffed shoes and stringy hair and lint.
艾米喜欢考虑这些事情，购买这些东西。与我不同，我妹妹不会在妈妈想给她做家庭烫发时威胁要给国际特赦组织打电话。我对母亲来说有点丢脸——满是磨损的鞋子、乱糟糟的头发和绒毛。
Once, when Amy and I were 14, the three of us were getting out of the car after a trip to the mall. The neighbor woman, who was out watering her yard, saw the shopping bags and asked what we'd bought. Amy showed off her new candy-colored sweater and her hoop earrings and hot pink pants. The woman congratulated Amy. She then turned to me, pointing at the rectangular bulge protruding from the small brown bag in my hand. I reluctantly pulled out my single purchase-- a hardback of The Grapes of Wrath. My mother looked at the neighbor, rolled her eyes in my direction, and stage-whispered, "We're going through a book phase."
有一次，我和艾米14岁时，我们三人从商场购物回来刚下车。邻居妇女正在外面浇水，看到了购物袋，问我们买了什么。艾米炫耀着她新买的糖果色毛衣、圆圈耳环和亮粉色裤子。那个女人祝贺了艾米。然后她转向我，指着我手里棕色小纸袋里露出的长方形凸起。我不情愿地拿出了我的唯一购买——一本精装版的《愤怒的葡萄》。我母亲看着邻居，朝我翻了个白眼，然后像演戏一样压低嗓门说：“我们正在经历一个‘书本期’。”
And it's such a hopeful, almost utopian word, that word "phase." And now that we are finishing up the third decade of the book phase, we ask ourselves if we have changed. Sure, we still dress in the bruise palette of gray, black, and blue, and we still haven't gotten around to piercing our ears. But we wear lipstick now. We own high-heeled shoes. Concessions have been made.
那真是一个充满希望、近乎乌托邦的词，“阶段”。现在，当我们即将结束“书本期”的第三个十年时，我们问自己是否改变了。当然，我们仍然穿着灰色、黑色和蓝色的淤青色调，而且我们仍然没去穿耳洞。但我们现在涂口红了。我们拥有高跟鞋。我们做出了妥协。
Still, I have been called a curmudgeon by Bitch magazine. And that's the image I'm cultivating. But truth be told, I'm not as dour-looking as I would like. I'm stuck with this round, sweetie-pie face, tiny, heart-shaped lips, the daintiest dimples, and apple cheeks so rosy I exist in a perpetual blush. At five foot four, I barely squeak by average height. And then there's my voice-- straight out of second grade.
不过，我还是被《婊子》杂志称为刻薄鬼。那也是我正在塑造的形象。但说实话，我并没有我想要的那么阴沉。我这张圆圆的甜心脸、小巧的心形嘴唇、最精致的酒窝，还有苹果肌，红润得仿佛一直在脸红。我身高五英尺四英寸，勉强挤进平均身高。还有我的声音——完全是小学生的水平。
I come across so young and innocent and harmless that I have been carded for buying maple syrup. Tourists feel more than safe approaching me for directions. Telemarketers always ask if my mother is home. And waitresses always, always call me "hon."
我给人的感觉太年轻、无辜且无害，以至于我买枫糖浆时都会被查身份证。游客觉得找我问路非常安全。电话推销员总是问我妈妈在家吗。服务员总是、总是叫我“亲爱的”。
So the last time I got my hair cut, I asked my hairdresser if he could make me look more menacing. I said I admired Marilyn Manson's new hairdo, and could he make me look like that? And even though my hairdresser is German and everything, when he was done with me, I have never in my life looked so sickeningly nice.
所以上次剪头发时，我问理发师能不能让我看起来更凶狠一点。我说我很欣赏玛丽莲·曼森的新发型，他能不能让我看起来那样？尽管我的理发师是德国人什么的，但当他剪完后，我这辈子从来没有显得如此令人恶心地讨人喜欢。
Is it too much to ask to make strangers nervous, to look shady and untrustworthy and malcontent? Something needed to be done.
让陌生人感到紧张、看起来阴郁、不可信、愤世嫉俗，这要求很高吗？必须得做点什么。
I happened to hear about a group of goths in San Francisco who offered goth makeovers to civilians and then take them to a goth club to see if they can pass. Goths, for those unfamiliar with this particular subculture, are the pale-faced, black-clad vampiric types with forlorn stares framed by raccoon eye makeup. The name derives, of course, from gothic, a style, according to my dictionary, emphasizing the grotesque, mysterious, and desolate.
我碰巧听说旧金山有一群哥特族，他们为普通人提供哥特式改造，然后带他们去哥特俱乐部看看他们能否过关。哥特族，对于那些不熟悉这一特定亚文化的人来说，是那些面色苍白、身穿黑衣、如吸血鬼般的人，表情忧郁，映衬在浣熊般的眼妆中。这个名字当然源自“哥特式”，根据我的词典，这是一种强调怪诞、神秘和荒凉的风格。
So I called Mary Mitchell, aka Mary Queen of Hurts, and asked for a private lesson in goth. She just told me to come to San Francisco and pack some black clothes, and she and her team of expert goths would handle the rest. Coming up with black apparel for the occasion wasn't particularly problematic for me. One might describe my closet as Johnny Cash once described his-- "It's dark in there."
所以我打电话给玛丽·米切尔，也就是“伤痛女王玛丽”，要求上一堂哥特私教课。她只是叫我来旧金山，带点黑色衣服，她和她的哥特专家团队会处理剩下的事。为这个场合找黑衣服对我来说并不是什么大问题。你可以用约翰尼·卡什曾经形容他衣柜的话来形容我的：“里面一片漆黑。”
And I've always admired the goths. There's something brave about them, something romantic and feminine and free, not to mention refreshingly honest. If the funny T-shirt slogans and crisp khaki pants of the average American tell the lie that everything's going to be OK, the black lace garbs and ghoulish capes of goth tell the truth-- that you suffer, then you die. The goths literally wear their hearts on their tattered sleeves, frankly daring the world to stare at their inner ugliness, and stare hard.
我一直很钦佩哥特族。他们身上有一种勇敢，一种浪漫、女性化和自由的东西，更不用说那种令人耳目一新的诚实。如果普通美国人有趣的T恤标语和干练的卡其裤在撒谎，声称一切都会好起来，那么哥特族的黑色蕾丝装束和恐怖斗篷则是在说实话——你受苦，然后你死去。哥特族确实将他们的内心穿在褴褛的袖子上，坦率地挑战世界去注视他们内在的丑陋，并狠狠地盯着看。
I reported to a Market Street address where I met the five members of my death-warmed-over beauty squad. I met Indra, a gorgeous blonde in a long velvet skirt; Terrance, dashing in a velvet smoking jacket; the tall, dark Monique; Elizabeth, in strappy black leather; and, of course Mary, whose seven-inch patent leather heels would relegate her later on to dancing only to the slowest songs for fear of tipping over.
我按地址来到市场街，见到了我的五人“死而复生”美容小队。我见到了因德拉，一位身穿长天鹅绒裙的华丽金发女郎；穿着天鹅绒吸烟夹克显得风度翩翩的泰伦斯；身材高大、皮肤黝黑的莫妮克；穿着黑色细带皮衣的伊丽莎白；当然还有玛丽，她那七英寸的漆皮高跟鞋让她后来只能跳最慢的舞曲，以免摔倒。
Prior to meeting Mary Queen of Hurts, I found her sadistic nickname entirely appropriate, as she assigned me goth homework to do before my arrival. The assignment consisted of going through a punchy little primer she wrote with Indra and Terrance which outlines the seven steps to "gothitude." Step number six asked me to go through my records and pull out the darkest, saddest song, and play it over and over again. Though the darkest, saddest stuff in my collection is all old country music. So my goth soundtrack is Roy Acuff's godless drunk-driving car-crash number, "Wreck on the Highway." Hit it, boys!
在见到“伤痛女王玛丽”之前，我发现她那虐待狂般的绰号非常贴切，因为她在我不远万里赶来之前就给我布置了哥特家庭作业。作业包括阅读她与因德拉和泰伦斯共同撰写的充满冲击力的小册子，其中概述了“哥特态度”的七个步骤。第六步要求我翻翻我的唱片，找出最黑暗、最悲伤的歌，一遍又一遍地播放。虽然我收藏中最黑暗、最悲伤的东西都是老乡村音乐。所以我的哥特配乐是罗伊·阿卡夫那首关于无神论者酒后驾车车祸的歌曲——《高速公路上的残骸》。开始吧，伙计们！
[MUSIC - "WRECK ON THE HIGHWAY"]
（音乐——《高速公路上的残骸》）
The whiskey and blood ran together mixed in the glass where they lay. Death played her hand in destruction but I didn't hear nobody pray.
威士忌和鲜血混在一起，流淌在他们躺着的玻璃杯里。死神在毁灭中施展了手段，但我没听到有人祈祷。
Before anyone breaks out the eyeliner, we all sit in a circle and go through my homework. The whole thing reminds me of graduate school seminars, except these people are smart and funny and have something interesting to say. They outline and debate the finer points of goth theory. They all turned goth in their early teens, and they are, as Indra puts it, "So in our thirties."
在任何人拿出眼线笔之前，我们围成一圈，检查我的作业。整个过程让我想起了研究生研讨会，只不过这些人聪明幽默，言之有物。他们概述并辩论了哥特理论的细节。他们都是在十几岁时转为哥特族的，而且正如因德拉所说，“我们已经三十多岁了”。
Step one of the guidelines is choosing a goth name. Indra says, "Most of us have changed our name to be something more gothic. A lot of people legally change their name." According to Mary, "If you go into any of the goth clubs nowadays, you'll find a lot of spooky names, like Raven and Rat and Sage."
准则的第一步是起一个哥特名字。因德拉说：“我们大多数人都改了名字，变得更哥特。很多人甚至在法律上改了名字。”据玛丽说：“如果你现在去任何哥特俱乐部，你会发现很多诡异的名字，比如‘乌鸦’、‘老鼠’和‘鼠尾草’。”
When I was pondering a good goth name for myself, I paged through my reference books on death and dying, looking for something gruesome. But nothing felt right. Maybe it's because I came of age in the '80s and I've seen Blue Velvet too many times, but to me, the really frightening stuff has nothing to do with ravens and rats. The truly sordid has a sunny, WASP-y glow. Therefore, I tell them, the most perverse name I can think of is "Becky."
当我在为自己构思一个好的哥特名字时，我翻阅了关于死亡和临终的参考书，寻找一些令人毛骨悚然的东西。但没有一个感觉对劲。也许是因为我在80年代长大，看过太多遍《蓝丝绒》，对我来说，真正可怕的东西与乌鸦和老鼠无关。真正肮脏的东西有一种阳光般的、盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒式的光泽。因此，我告诉他们，我能想到的最反叛的名字是“贝基”。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
It turns out, that by saying the magic word "Becky," I have suddenly moved to the head of the class, goth-wise. As Monique puts it, "You are understanding the pink of goth. You've skipped a couple levels, and you went straight to pink." The group's consensus is that pink is the apex of expert goth, that newcomers and neophytes should stick with basic black, but those confident enough, complex enough, can exude gloom and doom while wearing the color of sugar and spice. Indra argues that pink can be an intelligent, sarcastic color, though Terrance says of experimenting with pink, "Proceed with caution. I can't warn you enough."
结果证明，通过说出“贝基”这个魔力词，我在哥特层面上瞬间升到了班级之首。正如莫妮克所说：“你理解了‘哥特粉’的精髓。你跳过了几个级别，直接进入了粉色。”该团体的共识是，粉色是哥特专家的顶点，新手和菜鸟应该坚持基本的黑色，但那些足够自信、足够复杂的人，可以在身穿糖果和香料的颜色时散发出阴郁和毁灭的气息。因德拉认为粉色可以是一种聪明、讽刺的颜色，尽管泰伦斯在谈到尝试粉色时说：“慎重行事。我再怎么警告你都不为过。”
As if they need to warn me. It would never occur to me to wear pink, just as it would never occur to Michael Douglas to play a poor person.
好像他们需要警告我似的。我压根儿没想过穿粉色，就像迈克尔·道格拉斯压根儿没想过演个穷人一样。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
These, I realize, are my people. Simpatico. I think that's why, at that moment, I'm willing and able to do something with them that I was never able to do with my mom-- namely, sit still while they poke and prod and paint me, without complaint. I know I'm in the right hands when Terrance reassures me that "when we're done with you, no one will call you 'hon.'"
我意识到，这些人是我的同类。志趣相投。我想这就是为什么在那个时刻，我愿意并能够和他们一起做我从未能和我妈一起做的事——即一动不动地坐着，让他们戳、捅、涂抹我，而不抱怨。当泰伦斯向我保证“当我们改造完你，没人会再叫你‘亲爱的’”时，我知道我找对人了。
It's an astonishingly slow process. Indra decides to make me up like the silent film star Louise Brooks, shading in concentric circles of eyeshadow and then liquid eyeliner, which takes a full five minutes to dry. She agonizes over lipstick, applies a birthmark in the shape of a snake on my cheek. Then they dress me. By the time they're done cinching up the corset and stabilizing my bustle, I'm in so many layers of black lace scarves and fringe and fishnet stockings that I could play strip poker for three weeks straight without baring my belly button.
这是一个极其缓慢的过程。因德拉决定把我化妆成无声电影明星路易丝·布鲁克斯的样子，画上层层叠叠的同心圆眼影，然后涂上液体眼线，这花了整整五分钟才干透。她对口红精益求精，还在我脸颊上画了一个蛇形的痣。然后他们给我穿上衣服。等他们勒紧束身衣并固定好臀垫时，我身上已经披了无数层黑色蕾丝围巾、流苏和渔网袜，以至于我可以连续三个星期玩脱衣扑克而不露肚脐。
The finishing touches are applied in a full-on pit stop. I sit in a chair and Monique curls my hair while Terrance fusses with my lipstick and Mary paints my nails black, all at once. I find I enjoy this loving, methodical attention. I'm so pleased with the results that I keep looking in the mirror and smiling. I smile so much that Elizabeth reminds me that technically, a good goth is supposed to pout. But I'm too giddy.
最后的润色是在一次全面的“维修站”中完成的。我坐在椅子上，莫妮克在卷我的头发，泰伦斯在折腾我的口红，玛丽在给我涂黑指甲油，同时进行。我发现我很享受这种充满爱意、有条不紊的关注。我对结果非常满意，以至于我一直照镜子微笑。我笑得太多，伊丽莎白提醒我，严格来说，一个好的哥特族应该嘟囔着嘴。但我太高兴了。
Something occurs to me. What if all those years, my mom wanted to do just this-- sit me down and fiddle with my hair, not because she wanted to torture me, or because she was embarrassed about how I looked, or because she missed her job. What if she wanted to do this for me to show me that she loves me? If all along, she was trying to give me the feeling I'm getting from these strangers? I thought she was the oppressor and I was the victim. But it's just as true the other way around.
我突然想到一件事。如果这些年来，我妈妈想做的就是这件事呢——让我坐下来，摆弄我的头发，不是因为她想折磨我，或者因为她对我的长相感到尴尬，或者因为她怀念她的工作。如果她是想通过这种方式向我展示她爱我呢？如果她一直以来都是在试图给我这种从这些陌生人身上得到的感受？我以为她是压迫者，我是受害者。但反过来也同样成立。
It was time to go to the club. But after two hours of primping, I was tired. I ask them if they ever spend so much time doing their hair and makeup that they're too pooped to go out. They said that for this very reason, there is a goth rule. You have to stay at the club at least as long as it takes to get dressed up.
是时候去俱乐部了。但在两小时的梳妆打扮后，我累坏了。我问他们，他们是否曾经花太多时间做头发和化妆，以至于累得不想出门。他们说正因为如此，有一条哥特准则：你必须在俱乐部呆的时间，至少要和打扮的时间一样长。
The club we go to is called Roderick's Chamber, cheerfully named for a character in Edgar Allan Poe's "Fall of the House of Usher." Everywhere blackness, leather, lace, frowns. And music. But while regular dance club music clips by at the pace "wah wah wah wah-wah wah-wah wah wah," the goth club music is sluggish, slowed down. "Wah-- wah-- wah-- wah wah wah wah-- wah wah."
我们去的俱乐部叫“罗德里克的密室”，这个名字愉快地取自埃德加·爱伦·坡小说《厄舍府的崩塌》中的一个角色。到处都是黑色、皮革、蕾丝、皱眉。还有音乐。但虽然普通的舞蹈俱乐部音乐以“哇-哇-哇-哇哇哇”的节奏跳动，哥特俱乐部的音乐却迟缓而拖沓。“哇——哇——哇——哇哇哇哇——哇哇”。
[MUSIC - GOTHY CLUB TUNE]
（音乐——哥特俱乐部曲调）
The thing I love most about the goth club is how passive it is. Hardly anyone talks to anyone else. It is free of the normal social pressures to smile, and interact, and appear content. There's none of that "getting to know you" pick-up crap. In fact, the mood is antithetical to pick-ups. It's more like, stay away. No one cares if you dance. No one cares if you don't. As someone who often dreads strangers, the anti-social nature of this social situation makes me feel communal and part of something, one of us. Like, "hey, I hate talking to you, too!" It is completely liberating.
我最喜欢哥特俱乐部的一点是它的被动性。几乎没有人与其他人交谈。它没有那种需要微笑、互动和表现得心满意足的正常社会压力。没有那种“了解你”的搭讪废话。事实上，这种氛围与搭讪完全相反。更像是：离我远点。没人关心你是否跳舞。没人关心你是否跳舞。作为一名经常惧怕陌生人的人，这种社交场合的反社交本质让我感到一种共鸣，成为一部分，成为“我们”中的一员。就像是，“嘿，我也讨厌和你说话！”这完全是一种解放。
The whole point of going there is to stare and be stared at. Someone walking in off the street might think, what's the fun in that? And the answer is, all the interaction, all the fun, all the real moments happen at home when you're getting dressed, talking to your friends about how you'll look. The club is about being seen, which is so inferior.
去那里的全部意义在于注视和被注视。路人可能会想，这有什么好玩的？答案是，所有的互动、所有的乐趣、所有真实的时刻，都发生在你待在家里打扮时，和你朋友讨论你看起来会怎样的时候。俱乐部是关于被看的，那太次要了。
After the mandatory two hours, I hug my goths goodbye and hail a cab. Usually I am a cab driver's dream-- polite, small, nonthreatening. Perhaps that is why cab drivers always talk to me. But tonight, I am Becky. I am goth. Not a word from the driver. Bless him, he keeps staring at me and my eye makeup in the rear-view mirror, watching his back. She is menacing, he's thinking. I can tell.
在规定的两小时后，我拥抱了我的哥特伙伴，打了辆车。通常我是出租车司机的梦幻乘客——有礼貌、体型小、无威胁。也许这就是为什么司机总是跟我说话。但今晚，我是“贝基”。我是哥特族。司机一言不发。上帝保佑他，他一直从后视镜里盯着我和我的眼妆，提防着背后。她在打坏主意，他心里在想。我看得出来。
His fear pays off. I tip him extravagantly. So extravagantly that I blow my cover. He turns and gives me a look that says, "Thanks, hon."
他的恐惧得到了回报。我给了他丰厚的小费。丰厚到暴露了我的身份。他转过头，给了我一个眼神，仿佛在说：“谢谢，亲爱的。”
Sarah Vowell.
莎拉·沃威尔。
[MUSIC - "SHOEHORN WITH TEETH" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
（音乐——“他们可能是巨人”乐队的《长牙的鞋拔子》）
Mr. Dan Hickey, ladies and gentlemen.
丹·希基先生，女士们先生们。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Act Two, Lifesavers.
第二幕，“救生员”。
Last month I was doing this project as a favor for a friend where I was interviewing a lot of kids in arts programs around the city of Chicago. And as part of that project, I met this 18-year-old girl named Lucia Lopez. Back when she was 16, through a sort of fluke, Lucia joined a group called Music Theatre Workshop in Chicago. And it happened some kids basically just came through the neighborhood interviewing teenagers about their lives, and then those kids wrote a play about what they got, and invited Lucia to be in the play, to play herself.
上个月，我为一个朋友做了一个项目，采访了芝加哥全市艺术项目中很多孩子。作为项目的一部分，我遇到了这位18岁的女孩，露西娅·洛佩兹。回到她16岁时，通过某种偶然的机会，露西娅加入了一个名为芝加哥音乐剧工作坊的团体。那时正好有一些孩子来社区采访青少年关于他们的生活，然后那些孩子写了一部关于他们所见所闻的戏，并邀请露西娅参演，扮演她自己。
And at first, when she joined the group, the other kids were scared of her. She was much tougher, much more street, in a gang. Most of her family was in the gang, which in Chicago is a kind of common formulation. She herself had served time in juvie.
起初，当她加入团队时，其他孩子都很怕她。她更强硬，更社会化，在帮派里。她的大部分家人都在帮派中，这在芝加哥是一种普遍情况。她自己也曾因在少年管教所服刑。
Yeah, I went to people, like, what are you looking at? Do have a problem? Well, do I look like somebody or am I somebody? And then people would be like, no, I ain't looking at you. I was just wondering who you are. And I'm like, well, keep on wondering because you know, whatever, but don't be looking at me like that. Because, you know, something could kick off.
是的，我曾对人说，比如，“你在看什么？你有问题吗？我是哪号人物还是怎么着？”然后人们会说，不，我没看你。我只是好奇你是谁。我就说，好吧，继续好奇吧，随便，但别那样看着我。因为你知道，随时可能打起来。
Since I grew up in my house with having violence. Like when my stepfather is a very violent man. So it was like one of those things that it was an instinct. If anybody touched me, it was right there and then, we had to hit. And plus, like--
我从小在家里成长，充斥着暴力。比如我的继父是个非常暴力的人。所以这就像是一种本能。如果有人碰我，当时就要还手。而且，就像——
You had to hit?
你必须打人？
Well, you know. It was just like that. If anybody even stared at me, it was like, what are you looking at? Do you have a problem? [? Because you know it would ?] start it off, so we could just kick it off right here and there.
好吧，你知道。就是那样。如果有人甚至盯着我，就好像是在说，“你在看什么？你有问题吗？”[？因为你知道它会？]引起事端，所以我们当时就能直接打起来。
Not long after she started with the theater group, she missed two rehearsals in a row, and the head of the group, Meade Palidofsky, replaced her in the show with another girl. Rules are rules.
在她开始加入戏剧小组后不久，她连续两次错过排练，小组负责人米德·帕利多夫斯基用另一个女孩取代了她在戏中的位置。规矩就是规矩。
Then Lucia came back. What was especially galling to her was that this other girl, Ruchelle, was going to be onstage, reciting Lucia's life story, things that had happened to Lucia that were in the script. Meade and another girl in the group tell what happened when Lucia showed up again.
然后露西娅回来了。让她特别生气的是，那个女孩，鲁谢尔，要在舞台上朗诵露西娅的人生故事，那些发生在露西娅身上并写进剧本里的事。米德和小组里的另一个女孩讲述了露西娅再次出现时发生的事情。
Well, she was upset, but she was-- when she came back in and I told her that Ruchelle had taken her place, she was like, I'm going to go beat her up. I mean, I had to stop her. I said, no, if you're going to beat somebody up, you should beat me up, because I'm the one that gave her the part.
嗯，她很难过，但是——当她回来，我告诉她鲁谢尔已经取代了她的位置时，她说，我要去打她一顿。我的意思是，我不得不阻止她。我说，不，如果你要打人，你应该打我，因为是我给了她那个角色。
And the rest of us were sent to an early lunch that day.
然后我们其他人那天被送去提前吃午饭了。
Exactly. So I had to calm her down and say no, don't beat Ruchelle up, you know? It's all right. And we talked to her, and eventually we split the part up. We realized how much it meant to her, but then she also had to realize that if it meant that much, she needed to come to rehearsal.
没错。所以我不得不让她冷静下来，说不，不要打鲁谢尔，你知道吗？没关系。我们和她谈了谈，最终我们把角色分开了。我们意识到这对她意味着什么，但她也必须意识到，如果这意义重大，她就需要来排练。
Back when she entered public school, like a lot of kids from her neighborhood, Lucia didn't speak English, didn't do well. As she got older, she found herself getting mad at the other kids, fighting all the time.
当她上公立学校时，就像她所在社区的很多孩子一样，露西娅不会说英语，成绩不好。随着年龄增长，她发现自己对其他孩子很生气，一直在打架。
And I can't get a decent sleep ever. I go to school with this image in my head, like, oh my god, I see my mom's head getting bashed in the walls. And it's just like, I think that's what turned me into a very violent kid. Just, you know, the kids being happy was very tough for me. Because I was like, why can't I have fun like that? Why can't I live like that? Why is it so difficult?
我从来都没睡过一个安稳觉。我脑子里带着这种画面上学，比如，天哪，我看见我妈的头在墙上被撞碎了。我觉得这把我变成了一个非常有暴力的孩子。你知道，看着孩子们开心地玩，对我来说太难了。因为我心想，为什么我不能那样享受生活？为什么我不能那样生活？为什么那么难？
I was really bad. I was very bad with teachers. If a teacher were to even tell me, Lucia, be quiet! Whatever. I felt that as an attack, so I was like, well, they're going to attack me. I should attack first. There was points where I smacked teachers, throwing chairs, whatever. You name it.
我真的很坏。我对老师非常坏。如果老师甚至跟我说，“露西娅，安静点！”什么的。我把它视为攻击，所以我就想，好吧，他们要攻击我。我应该先发制人。我有过掌掴老师、乱扔椅子等等的时候。你说得出来的坏事我都干过。
And since I was a little girl growing up, I never, never had an OK day. Do you understand me? I never had anything like, you know, it's going to be cool today. It's going to be OK. You're not going to hear one of your friends dead, and you're not going to hear your dad coming in the house, beating up on your mom. You're not going to hear that. It's just going to be OK. And that was just one of the things that-- I just go into a whole different world.
从我小女孩的时候起，我从来、从来没过过好日子。你明白吗？我从没觉得有什么事情是，比如，今天会很酷。会没事的。你不会听到你的一个朋友死了，你也不会听到你爸回家毒打你妈。你听不到那些。就是会没事的。而那只是让我……进入了一个完全不同的世界。
To hear Lucia tell it, she had never met kids like the ones in the theater group-- kids who were strong and independent, but who weren't in a gang. And at first they were literally incomprehensible. The way they goofed around with each other, the way they talked to each other-- she'd just watch them, trying to understand why they acted the way they did. Why were they so happy all the time?
听露西娅叙述，她从未见过像戏剧小组里那样的孩子——那些坚强而独立，但不在帮派里的孩子。起初，他们简直不可思议。他们相互打闹的方式，他们交谈的方式——她只是看着他们，试图理解为什么他们会那样做。为什么他们总是那么开心？
I just started seeing, these kids weren't in gangs. And they had the time of their lives, you know? And I had a lot of them telling me, you don't have to be there. You don't have to do this and that.
我刚开始意识到，这些孩子不在帮派里。他们过着自己最美好的人生，你知道吗？我有很多孩子告诉我，你不必在那里。你不必做这个或那个。
You mean, the MCW kids were saying, you don't have to be in a gang.
你是说，音乐剧工作坊的孩子们在说，你不必在帮派里。
And then just to hear somebody from my age to tell me that, that really turned me on. I was like, huh. To have this person's my age and they're thinking like this. Why don't I think like that? I always thought, man, what's wrong with me?
听到一个和我同龄的人这么说，真的触动了我。我想，嗯。这个人和我同龄，他们却这么想。为什么我不那样想？我总是想，伙计，我怎么了？
They were the only people in her life who were urging her to change, to quit the gang. Everybody else in her life was either in the gang or close to it. And I should just point out, this is very common. So many gang kids that you meet in Chicago-- if you ask, is anybody trying to convince you to quit the gang? They'll tell you no.
他们是她生命中唯一敦促她改变、退出帮派的人。她生命中其他人都要么在帮派里，要么与之有关联。我应该指出，这很普遍。你在芝加哥遇到的很多帮派孩子——如果你问他们，有没有人试图劝你退出帮派？他们会告诉你没有。
And central to the change that Lucia had to go through was this whole idea of, what are you looking at? Is it OK for somebody to just look at you without it turning into some kind of fight? And for a long time, even in the theater group, she struggled, and she just thought, no.
而露西娅必须经历的改变的核心是这个想法：“你在看什么？”有人看着你而不演变成某种争斗，这正常吗？很长一段时间，即使在戏剧小组里，她也在挣扎，她只是认为，不正常。
And if you looked at me in any wrong way, no matter how you looked at me, man, you'll be dealt with.
如果你以任何错误的方式看我，不管你怎么看我，伙计，你都会倒霉的。
You know what's so weird, is that you got out of the whole thing by putting yourself in a position where you're onstage and people are looking at you.
你知道最奇怪的是什么吗？是你通过让自己站在舞台上，让别人注视着你，才走出了这一切。
Yeah, exactly. I'll be like, wow, you know? I guess I got to get used to it. I was thinking, I can't be attacking everybody who's looking at me doing the play.
是的，没错。我会想，哇，你知道吗？我想我得习惯它。我在想，我不能攻击每一个在看我演戏的人。
So you'd be standing onstage, in a play, in costume, and you'd look out, and you'd see all these people looking at you. And going through your mind would be--
所以你会站在舞台上，在戏里，穿着戏服，向外看，看到所有这些人注视着你。而你脑子里在想——
Yeah, like, what the hell are you looking at? [INAUDIBLE] What's your problem or whatever? Yeah, just like, oh, what are they looking at me for? Just like, man, should I tell them something? Should I go on the mike and say, do you all have a problem? Should I be attacking? This is what's going through my mind.
是的，就像，你们这些人在看什么？[听不清]你们有什么问题或者别的什么？是的，就像，哦，他们为什么看我？就是，伙计，我应该告诉他们什么吗？我应该拿着麦克风说，你们都有问题吗？我应该攻击吗？这就是我脑子里在想的。
A researcher at Stanford University named Shirley Brice Heath has done this remarkable study where she sent a team of researchers into 120 afterschool programs for kids over the course of 10 years. And seven years into the study, she found this result that she was not even looking for. It turns out that arts programs were more effective in changing kids' lives than any other kind of program for kids. More than sports and academic programs, more than community service programs, the art kids not only tended to come from worse backgrounds than kids in the other programs-- that is, they were more likely to have a parent who was unemployed, they were more likely to have friends who were dropouts, they were more likely to get into fights at school. But after being in these programs, they became kids who were more likely to read for pleasure, they were more likely to be in honor societies, get academic honors, they were more entrepreneurial, they started projects, they were more willing to teach other kids.
斯坦福大学的一位研究员雪莉·布莱斯·希斯做了一项了不起的研究，她派遣了一个研究团队在10年内深入120个课外项目调查孩子。在研究进行到第七年时，她发现了一个她甚至没在寻找的结果。事实证明，艺术项目在改变孩子的生活方面比任何其他项目都更有效。比起体育和学术项目，比起社区服务项目，艺术项目的孩子们不仅往往来自比其他项目孩子更糟糕的背景——也就是说，他们更有可能有失业的父母，更有可能有辍学的朋友，更有可能在学校打架。但在参加这些项目后，他们变得更喜欢阅读，更有可能进入荣誉社团，获得学术荣誉，他们更具创业精神，他们发起项目，更愿意教导其他孩子。
Shirley Brice Heath said that's because the arts programs tended to involve kids in more complicated collaborations with each other. They were just doing harder stuff, and they were critiquing it, and making big plans, and contingency plans, and reevaluating plans. And they learned all these verbal skills.
雪莉·布莱斯·希斯说，那是因为艺术项目往往涉及孩子们之间更复杂的协作。他们只是在做更难的事情，他们在进行批判、制定宏伟计划、应急计划，并重新评估计划。他们学习了所有这些语言能力。
Her study also showed that although those programs are the most effective at helping the kids who are the most at risk in our society, they have a terrible time staying afloat. Nine out of ten of them can't find funding sources and die within eight years. The program that Lucia was in is constantly struggling for money. Music Theatre Workshop, great program. Constantly struggling for funding.
她的研究还表明，尽管这些项目在帮助我们社会中最处于危险的孩子方面最有效，但它们很难维持下去。十个项目中有九个找不到资金来源，并在八年内倒闭。露西娅所在的那个项目一直在为钱发愁。音乐剧工作坊，伟大的项目。一直在为资金挣扎。
I asked Lucia if it mattered that this was an arts group that she was in, that they were doing a play. Wouldn't she have changed if she had fallen in with any group of kids who she liked, who were not in gangs, who she could get to know this way? And she said, absolutely not. She said part of what helped her change so much, part of what helped her quit the gang and go to school had specifically to do with the fact that it was a play, that it was art doing what art does, if you're lucky, which is change you.
我问露西娅，她在的这个艺术小组是否重要？如果她加入了任何她喜欢、不在帮派里、她可以通过这种方式结识的孩子，她会不会改变？她说，绝对不会。她说帮助她改变如此之多的一部分，帮助她退出帮派并去上学的一部分，正是因为这是一部戏，是艺术在做它该做的事——如果你幸运的话——那就是改变你。
I think the play did it a lot, the play itself. Because like I said, since it was part of my life story and stuff, and playing it-- since you're doing it over and over, it's like one of the things that you're just letting it go. You put just everything. Like how can I say it? The whole drama skit of your whole life, just on paper. Let it fly away, whatever. Let it be thrown in the garbage. Just-- it happened.
我觉得这出戏真的起了很大作用，这部戏本身。因为就像我说的，因为它是我人生故事的一部分，而且是扮演它——因为你一遍又一遍地做，就像是在让你释放掉它。你投入了一切。我该怎么说呢？你整个人生的戏剧草图，全在纸上了。让它飞走，随它去吧。让它被扔进垃圾桶。就是——它发生过。
Time to move on.
是时候前进了。
Yeah. Exactly. Just live on, just live on with peace, finally. So that's one of the good things. Just with peace. And going to sleep better.
是的。没错。继续生活，带着平静继续生活，终于。所以这是好的事情之一。带着平静。而且睡得更好。
Well, it seemed wrong to fly all the way to New York from Chicago, to this huge, beautiful theater right off Broadway, and tell Lucia's story, and not give her the chance to come and perform herself. So doing a scene adapted from her Music Theatre Workshop play, please welcome 18-year-old Lucia Lopez.
好吧，从芝加哥飞到纽约，来到百老汇边上这个巨大、美丽的剧院，讲述露西娅的故事，而不让她有机会亲自来表演，这似乎是不对的。所以，表演一段改编自她音乐剧工作坊剧目的场景，欢迎18岁的露西娅·洛佩兹。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
They call it a walk by. It's five or six guys from another gang coming in slowly. Screaming and representing, wearing the masks on their face. Bullets are flying everywhere. And then I see Roberto, my brother's best friend, on the ground, holding his chest while he was trying to breathe. A lot of the ladies in the neighborhood start screaming from the windows, "We call 911!" The old ladies are praying with the rosaries.
他们称之为“路过杀戮”。那是来自另一个帮派的五六个家伙慢慢走过来。尖叫着展示他们的势力，脸上戴着面具。子弹到处乱飞。然后我看到罗伯托，我哥哥最好的朋友，躺在地上，捂着胸口喘气。社区里很多妇女开始从窗户尖叫：“我们报警了！”老太太们在用念珠祈祷。
Then the cops come to investigate. It takes a long time before the ambulance shows up. The cops even have time to question us, question the neighbors, and look in the bushes. The ambulance guys move really slowly. They pull out the stretcher. They talk to the cops. We scream at them, "Do something!"
然后警察来调查。救护车花了好长时间才出现。警察甚至有时间盘问我们、盘问邻居、在灌木丛里搜寻。救护车人员动作真的很慢。他们拉出担架。他们和警察交谈。我们冲他们尖叫：“做点什么！”
Meanwhile, two other guys who shot Roberto are walking around, making sure he's dying. If he doesn't die, then they'll wait to do another walk by. So they change their clothes so we can't recognize them. They took a look around to see who else is there or to see who they'll go after when they come back.
与此同时，另外两个开枪击中罗伯托的家伙走来走去，确认他正在死去。如果他不死，他们就会等着做另一次路过杀戮。所以他们换了衣服，这样我们就认不出他们了。他们四处观察，看看还有谁在那儿，或者看看他们回来时会去找谁麻烦。
Roberto's still breathing. Everyone's telling the paramedics to hurry up while the ladies are still yelling at them in Spanish. [SPEAKING SPANISH] I hope it happens to you. The paramedics just take a look at them like, what are you saying? They take a look at Roberto. They see his baggy clothes, his gang colors, his gold chain. They see that he is Mexican and they don't care. They don't want to go near him. They don't want to touch him.
罗伯托还在呼吸。每个人都在催促医护人员快点，而女人们还在用西班牙语对他们大喊大叫。[讲西班牙语]我希望这发生在你们身上。医护人员只是看着他们，仿佛在说，你们在说什么？他们看着罗伯托。他们看到他宽大的衣服、帮派色彩、金链子。他们看到他是墨西哥人，而他们不在乎。他们不想靠近他。他们不想碰他。
But I see him, bleeding with his eyes, breathing, trying to grasp what little life he had left. One of the paramedics says, "Why should we even bother? He's in a gang. We fix him up and he'll just got shot again." I'm thinking to myself, he's still alive. He heard them say this. His eyes are looking into mine. Please, get them to do something.
但我看着他，眼睛里流着血，呼吸着，试图抓住他仅存的那点生命。其中一个医护人员说：“我们甚至为什么要费事？他是帮派成员。我们救好他，他只会再次被枪击。”我心里想，他还活着。他听见他们这么说。他的眼睛盯着我的眼睛。求求你们，让他们做点什么。
Finally, they pick up Roberto. They throw him in the ambulance, slam the door shut, and drive off. Everybody stands there a moment, not knowing what to do.
最后，他们抬起了罗伯托。他们把他扔进救护车，砰地关上门，开车离去。每个人都站在那里片刻，不知道该做什么。
But I wanted to run after them. Strangle them. Show them what we have to go through. Walk over their dying bodies and do nothing. But instead, I turned around like everyone else and went home.
但我想要追上他们。勒死他们。让他们看看我们必须经历什么。从他们垂死的尸体上走过去，什么也不做。但相反，我像其他人一样转过身，回家了。
Roberto died before he even got to the hospital, before his mother even got to see him. The only people with him when he died were those paramedics. He spent his last moments of his life with those three guys.
罗伯托甚至没到医院就死了，甚至在他母亲见到他之前就死了。他死时身边唯一的人就是那些医护人员。他生命的最后时刻是和那三个家伙在一起。
Thank you.
谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Lucia Lopez.
露西娅·洛佩兹。
[MUSIC - "SHE'S ACTUAL SIZE" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
（音乐——“他们可能是巨人”乐队的《她就是真人大小》）
They Might Be Giants. Coming up-- climb every mountain, ford every stream, follow every rainbow. Just do it without me. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
“他们可能是巨人”。接下来——攀登每一座山，渡过每一条溪流，跟随每一道彩虹。只是不要带着我。稍后我们的节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Coming to you today from the stage of Town Hall in New York City.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在纽约市政厅的舞台上为您播出。
Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme. Today, from the stage, with hundreds of people looking at us-- What Are You Lookin' At? We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Climb Every Mountain.
每周节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者对该主题进行探讨。今天，在舞台上，在数百人的注视下——“你在看什么？”我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“攀登每一座山”。
Adulthood means, among other things, pretending to be confident in situations where you feel anything but. "What are you looking at?" is the question that blares through our heads in moments when it feels like the veneer of adulthood is not convincing anyone. David Rakoff was born in Toronto, moved to New York when he was a teenager. He has so successfully learned to pass himself off as a native New Yorker that usually even he believes he's one. The only problem is, sometimes he has to actually leave the five boroughs of New York City. Please welcome David Rakoff.
成年意味着，除其他事项外，在感到任何不自信的情况下假装自信。“你在看什么？”是我们在感到成年人的外表无法说服任何人时，在我们脑海中回响的问题。大卫·拉科夫在多伦多出生，青少年时期搬到纽约。他非常成功地伪装成一名土生土长的纽约客，以至于通常连他自己都相信他是。唯一的问题是，有时他必须真的离开纽约市的五个行政区。欢迎大卫·拉科夫。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
I do not go outdoors. Not more than I have to. As far as I'm concerned, the whole point of living in New York City is indoors. You want greenery? Order the spinach.
我不出门。除非必须。在我看来，住在纽约市的全部意义就在于室内。想要绿色植物？点份菠菜吧。
Paradoxically, I am being sent by an outdoor adventure magazine to climb a mountain on Christmas Day with a man named Larry Davis. Larry has climbed Mount Monadnock in southwestern New Hampshire every day for the last five plus years. I will join him on ascent number 2,065.
自相矛盾的是，我被一家户外探险杂志派去和一名叫拉里·戴维斯的男人在圣诞节那天爬山。拉里在过去五年多里每天都爬新罕布什尔州西南部的莫纳德诺克山。我将加入他进行第2,065次攀登。
The trip up to New Hampshire will involve a tiny plane from Boston. I tear my medicine cabinet apart like Billie Holiday and still only uncover one Xanax. The hiking boots the magazine sent me to buy, large, ungainly potato-like things that I've been trying to break in for the past four days, cut into my feet and draw blood as if they were lined with cheese graters. I have come to hate these Timberlands with a fervor I usually reserve for people. Just think, the shoes I wouldn't be caught dead in might just turn out to be the shoes I am caught dead in.
去新罕布什尔州的行程将涉及从波士顿出发的一架小飞机。我像比莉·荷莉黛一样翻遍了我的药柜，却只翻出一片阿普唑仑。杂志让我买的登山靴——那是双巨大、笨拙、像马铃薯一样的东西，过去四天我一直试图把它穿合脚，但它磨破了我的脚，流了血，仿佛里面衬着奶酪刨丝器。我已经开始以一种通常留给人类的狂热来痛恨这些添柏岚（Timberlands）了。想想看，我死也不想穿的鞋子，可能恰恰是我死时穿的鞋子。
It bears mentioning here that Monadnock is not Everest. It is 3,000 feet high and the most climbed mountain in the world. It's not even a real mountain.
这里值得一提的是，莫纳德诺克山不是珠穆朗玛峰。它有3,000英尺高，是世界上被攀登次数最多的山。它甚至不是一座真正的山。
I do not let this sway me from my worrying. I have other reasons for concern. My status as an adult perpetually teeters on the verge of being exposed as a sham and revoked. Plus, I am only playing at reporter here. I have, up to this point, relied upon my relentlessly jokey, glib, runny-mouthed logorrhea and the unwarranted good graces of magazine editors who just let me make stuff up. I have never been sent anywhere on someone else's dime, and it takes all of my strength not to call my editor and tell him that the jig is finally up, that I cannot do this piece. It seems too bad that the jig has to be up so far from my home in New York, with its excitement, bright lights, and major teaching hospitals.
我没有让这点减轻我的担忧。我有其他担心的理由。我作为成年人的身份永远处于被揭露为骗局并被撤销的边缘。此外，我在这里只是在玩弄记者的角色。到目前为止，我一直依赖我那没完没了、油嘴滑舌的废话，以及杂志编辑们无端的青睐，他们只是任由我胡编乱造。我从未被派到任何地方花别人的钱，我使尽全力才忍住没给编辑打电话说把戏终于拆穿了，我写不了这篇报道。这看起来太糟糕了，把戏竟然是在离我纽约家中那么远的地方拆穿的，那里有刺激、明亮的灯光和大型教学医院。
The central drama of my life is about being a fraud, alas. that's a complete lie, really. The central drama in my life is actually about being lonely and thin, but fraudulence gets a fair amount of play.
唉，我生命中的核心戏剧是关于作为一个骗子。那其实是个彻底的谎言。我生命中的核心戏剧其实是关于孤独和瘦弱，但欺诈行为占了相当大的戏份。
At the connecting airline at the Boston airport, I sit, the only dark-haired person among the broad-faced butter-eaters, wondering if my outdoors journalist drag-- flannel shirt, jeans, most hated boots of Satan's workshop, down jacket-- is fooling anybody. A brief flight and half a Xanax later, I land in New Hampshire, horrified to learn that the place where I'll be staying is a bed and breakfast, not a hotel. My heart sinks. That means there is probably neither television nor phone in my room, and I have very little patience for what is generally labeled charming. In particular, country charm. I have an intense dislike of flowered wallpaper. Ditto jam of all sorts.
在波士顿机场的转机航空区，我坐在那儿，是那些宽脸爱吃黄油的人中唯一的黑发者，心想我的户外记者装扮——法兰绒衬衫、牛仔裤、撒旦工厂里最令人讨厌的靴子、羽绒服——是不是糊弄住了任何人。在一次短暂的飞行和半片阿普唑仑后，我降落在新罕布什尔州，惊恐地得知我将要入住的地方是一家民宿，而不是酒店。我的心沉了下去。这意味着我的房间里可能既没有电视也没有电话，而且我对通常被称为“迷人”的东西几乎没有任何耐心。特别是乡村魅力。我极其不喜欢碎花壁纸。果酱之类的也一样。
The former is in all-too-abundant evidence when I enter, and the latter, I'm sure, lies in ominous wait somewhere in the cheery kitchen. There is a knotty pine bar off the entrance hall with a settee with several embroidered pillows. "I'd rather be golfing." "On the eighth day, God created golf." "Golfers have sex in some humorous, golf-related manner." Et cetera.
当我走进门时，前者极其丰富，而后者，我相信在充满欢快气氛的厨房里某个地方不祥地等着我。入口大厅旁边有一个节结松木吧台，上面有一组放着几只绣花枕头的长椅。“我宁愿去打高尔夫球。”“第八天，上帝创造了高尔夫。”“高尔夫球手以某种幽默的高尔夫相关方式进行性行为。”等等。
The proprietress is the kind of tall, stalwart woman of a certain age that used to be called "handsome." She is approximately nine feet tall. Her eyes are blue, resolute. Her faithful dog Charlie at her side. She smiles at me warmly and introduces herself as Annie, extending a hand the size of a frying pan. "You must be Dave," she says. In New England, everyone calls you Dave, regardless of however many times you might introduce yourself as David.
女主人是那种上了年纪、身材高大、坚定不移的女性，过去常被称为“英俊”。她大约有九英尺高。她的眼睛是蓝色的，坚毅。她忠实的狗查理在身旁。她热情地对我微笑，并自我介绍叫安妮，伸出一只煎锅大小的手。“你一定是戴夫，”她说。在新英格兰，每个人都叫你戴夫，无论你做了多少次自我介绍说你是大卫。
I'm reminded of those fanatically religious homophobes who stand on the steps of Saint Patrick's Cathedral during gay pride, holding signs that say, "Adam and Eve, not Adam and Steve." I have always wanted to go up to them and say, well, of course not Adam and Steve. Never Adam and Steve. It's Adam and Steven.
我记得那些在骄傲游行期间站在圣帕特里克大教堂台阶上的狂热宗教同性恋恐惧症患者，举着写有“亚当和夏娃，不是亚当和史蒂夫”的牌子。我一直想走到他们面前说，当然不是亚当和史蒂夫。永远不是亚当和史蒂夫。是亚当和史蒂文。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
"You're in room three," she continues. "Why don't you go into the dining room, and have some lunch, and then we'll talk some. Come on, Charlie dog." In spite of myself, I am charmed. She puts on a dark green slicker and knee-high Wellingtons and is out the door, presumably to chop the ice off the pond, deliver a calf, or simply raise a barn.
“你住在三号房间，”她继续说，“为什么你不去餐厅吃点午饭，然后我们再聊聊。来吧，查理狗狗。”尽管我很抗拒，但我还是被迷住了。她穿上一件深绿色雨衣和及膝威灵顿雨靴，出门去了，大概是去砍掉池塘里的冰、接生一头小牛，或者干脆建个谷仓。
I eat a club sandwich and drink some coffee to try to eradicate my Xanax buzz. I am trying to appear legitimate, masculine, adult, like I deserve to be there. Larry Davis stops by the inn. I shake his hand in a hardy, hale, fellow-well-met way. As my reward, he gives me dispensation to climb the next day in my $20 plastic Payless shoes.
我吃了一个俱乐部三明治，喝了点咖啡，试图消除我的阿普唑仑兴奋感。我努力表现得合乎常理、有男子气概、成熟，好像我理应出现在那儿似的。拉里·戴维斯顺道拜访了旅馆。我以一种健壮、健康、同伴般的方式握了他的手。作为奖励，他免除了我第二天必须穿那双20美元 Payless 塑料鞋攀登的负担。
I realize I've done almost no research for this trip, so I walk into downtown Jaffrey to check things out. This seems to smack to me of journalistic realness, a kind of topography as destiny, New Journalism, Joan Didion opening, perhaps. I am taking notes by speaking into a little tape recorder. Perhaps that is what attracts attention.
我意识到我这次旅行几乎没做任何调查，所以我走进贾弗里市区想打探一下情况。这对我来说似乎具有记者的真实性，一种地形即宿命，新新闻主义，乔恩·狄迪恩式的开场，也许吧。我正对着一台小录音机说话做记录。也许就是这点吸引了注意力。
Or perhaps it is that there is not another living creature out at 5:00 PM on Christmas Eve, because a car passes and immediately circles back. The driver rolls down his window and asks me if I want a lift. I do not. But "how nice," I think. He drives on.
或者也许是因为在平安夜下午5点，没有其他活物在外面，因为一辆车经过并立即绕了回来。司机摇下车窗问我是否需要搭便车。我不必。但我心想，“多好啊。”他开车走了。
I'm charmed by the congeniality of this interchange. How friendly. How uncreepy. I speak too soon. He circles back. He hands me a rectangular package in tartan wrapping paper. "Take this. The most-watched video in the world," he says. This man is giving me a copy of Forrest Gump ? "It's The Life of Jesus. " I beg off politely, claiming Judaic immunity. He drives on.
这种互动的亲和力让我着迷。多么友好。多么不让人毛骨悚然。我高兴得太早了。他又绕了回来。他递给我一个用格子包装纸包着的长方形包裹。“拿去。世界上观看次数最多的视频，”他说。这个人给我的《阿甘正传》副本？“这是《耶稣的生平》。”我礼貌地拒绝了，声称有犹太豁免权。他开车走了。
Here's an interrupting thought. If your therapist calls to reschedule your appointment, as mine did just at the moment I finished writing this part of the story, and you make him laugh, as always, and if in wrapping up, you say, "Well, I'll see you on Wednesday at 12:30 then," and he responds, "I'm looking forward to it," is that bad?
这里有个打断的想法。如果你的治疗师打电话来要重新预约你的诊疗时间，就像我写完这段故事时我的治疗师所做的那样，而且你让他笑了，像往常一样，如果在结束通话时你说，“好吧，那我们周三12:30见，”而他回答，“我期待着，”那是不好的吗？
I return to the inn, now wreathed in the kind of Christmas-in-New-England, warm-hearthed cheery verisimilitude that Ralph Lauren would burn down a synagogue to achieve. Nat King Cole's Christmas album plays at tooth-loosening decibels. I go upstairs and continue reading the new Truman Capote biography. The inn starts to fill up with families and couples who have come for Christmas Eve dinner. Alone, Jewish, and awash in unkind thoughts about Christmas and the countryside as I am, I stay out of sight, for the most part. I can hear general revelry and prandial merriment coming from the dining room.
我回到旅馆，这里现在被拉尔夫·劳伦愿意烧毁一座犹太教堂才能实现的那种新罕布什尔圣诞节、暖火炉、欢快的真实感所笼罩。纳·京·高尔的圣诞专辑以令人牙齿松动的分贝播放着。我上楼继续读那本新的杜鲁门·卡波特传记。旅馆开始挤满了来吃平安夜晚餐的家庭和夫妇。我独自一人，是犹太人，沉浸在对圣诞节和乡村生活的刻薄想法中，大部分时间我都尽量不露面。我能听到餐厅里传来的欢庆声和进餐时的热闹声。
Finally, I head directly into the bar of golf pillows. Annie is there with a couple. "Merry Christmas, Dave," she greets me. A retired airline pilot sits at the bar enjoying a decidedly un-New England cocktail with an orange slice, maraschino cherry, and pineapple spear crowding the glass. The bartender is a woman in a sweater knit with a portrait of a family of snow people. The wife of the couple also wears a sweater, knit with a smiling, holly-festooned teddy bear.
最后，我径直走进那个有高尔夫枕头的酒吧。安妮和一对夫妇在那里。“圣诞快乐，戴夫，”她向我打招呼。一位退休的飞行员坐在吧台边，享用着一杯带有橙片、马拉斯奇诺樱桃和菠萝块的绝非新英格兰风格的鸡尾酒，杯子里挤满了水果。调酒师是一位穿着针织毛衣的女性，上面印着一家雪人的肖像。那对夫妇中的妻子也穿着一件毛衣，上面针织着一只微笑着、装饰着冬青的泰迪熊。
The husband presents Annie with a very well-rendered framed watercolor of a widemouth bass. It's really very good, and I say so. "Well, we'll put it here to keep you company," says Annie, propping the frame up on the bar stool next to mine. I make sure to look at it attentively, my face frozen into the art appreciation rictus until Annie and the couple go into the dining room. Cricking my neck, I order a steak and a red wine.
丈夫向安妮赠送了一幅画得非常好的大嘴鲈鱼水彩画。真的非常棒，我也这么说了。“好吧，我们就把它放在这里陪伴你，”安妮说，把相框撑在吧台我旁边的凳子上。我确保自己专注地看着它，脸部凝固成那种欣赏艺术的僵硬表情，直到安妮和那对夫妇进入餐厅。我扭着脖子，点了一份牛排和一杯红酒。
"Are you the writer?" the bartender asks me. "The writer." Finally. Despite the fact, or precisely because this is just what I wanted, I reply, my voice far too bright, "Oh, god, no. I'm a complete idiot." She doesn't entirely know how to take this. She gives me the careful half-smile one levels at a very large, possibly erratic dog.
“你是那个作家吗？”调酒师问我。“那个作家。”终于。尽管事实上，或者正是因为这正是我想要的，我回答道，声音太明亮了，“哦，上帝，不。我是一个彻头彻尾的白痴。”她不完全知道该怎么对待这件事。她露出了那种对待一只非常大、可能不稳定的狗时才会露出的谨慎微笑。
The pilot is the anti-me, a man so utterly comfortable with himself that he can drink a cocktail with no fewer than three different pieces of fruit in it, and still seem the very picture of adulthood. He talks a while about fixing up houses. It's what he does in his retirement. His voice is velvet-soft and Atticus Finch-authoritative. But there's a sad whiff of mortality, a smell of old leaves, underneath everything he speaks of. It's a bit like watching This Old House hosted by Baudelaire.
那名飞行员是反面的我，一个与自己极其自在的人，他可以喝上一杯放着不少于三种不同水果的鸡尾酒，看起来仍然是成熟的化身。他谈了一会儿修理房屋的事。那是他退休后做的事情。他的声音像天鹅绒一样柔软，像《杀死一只知更鸟》里的阿提克斯·芬奇那样权威。但在他所说的一切之下，有一股悲伤的死亡气息，一股老叶子的味道。这有点像看波德莱尔主持的《老房子》。
The pilot leaves fairly early in the evening. I hope he had somewhere to go. Then again, I think, I don't have anywhere to go. Why am I so concerned with the imagined loneliness of a total stranger? Then again again, I actually am somewhere. I'm sitting in a bar of a New England inn on Christmas Eve. I am the writer, eating a steak, drinking alone, talking to the bartender. And even though I loathe animals, I lazily toss bits of popcorn to Charlie as he sits at the foot of my bar stool. It's just me and the bartender and my faithful dog. Plus my date, the widemouth bass, whom I've been ignoring.
飞行员很早就在晚上离开了。我希望他有地方可去。转念一想，我心想，我没有地方可去。为什么我这么关心一个完全陌生人的想象中的孤独？转念又一想，其实我是在某个地方。我正平安夜坐在新英格兰一家旅馆的酒吧里。我是那个作家，吃着牛排，独自喝酒，和调酒师交谈。尽管我憎恶动物，但我还是懒洋洋地往查理坐的凳子底下扔爆米花。只有我和调酒师以及我忠实的狗。外加我的舞伴，大嘴鲈鱼，我一直没理会他。
I fairly drip with authenticity now. I have let go of my paranoia about being scrutinized. I feel completely comfortable. So comfortable, in fact, that inexplicably, I find myself asking the bartender if there's either a synagogue or a gay bar in Jaffrey. I clearly feel the need to out myself to her in every possible way. Why stop there, I wonder, and not just go ahead and ask if there is a Canadian consulate nearby?
我现在完全散发出真实感。我已经放下了对自己被审视的偏执。我感到完全自在。事实上，舒服到莫名其妙地发现自己在问调酒师贾弗里是否有犹太教堂或同性恋酒吧。我显然觉得有必要在各方面向她出柜。我心想，为什么就此打住，不干脆直接问附近是否有加拿大领事馆呢？
She keeps refilling my wine glass as we talk. She cuts me an enormous piece of baklava. More popcorn for the dog. I have a mountain to climb in the morning, damn it.
在我们交谈时，她一直往我的酒杯里倒酒。她切了一大块果仁蜜饼给我。更多的爆米花给狗吃。该死的，明天我还要爬山呢。
My reverie is undone by the strange series of glottal kecks and surds coming from below. I look down to Charlie dog, whose neck is arching forward and back in an ominously regular, reverse peristaltic fashion. I find the words as my voice Dopplers up to a fairly effeminate and vaguely hysterical pitch. "I think the dog might be getting sick. The dog is getting sick. Oh my [UNINTELLIGIBLE], the dog is sick!"
我的沉思被下方传来的一系列奇怪的喉音和辅音所打断。我往下看查理狗狗，它的脖子正以一种不祥的规则的、反向蠕动的方式向前和向后拱起。随着我的声音多普勒效应般上升到一个相当阴柔和模糊歇斯底里的音调，我找到了词汇。“我想这只狗可能要生病了。这只狗要生病了。哦，我的[听不清]，这只狗病了！”
Charlie vomits out a small, viscous puddle for which, from my quick and queasy perusal, I am largely responsible. The bartender cleans it up without a second glance. Thoroughly unmasked, I settle up for dinner and take myself upstairs to sleep. And to all a good night.
查理呕吐出一小滩粘稠的东西，根据我快速而反胃的观察，这主要是我造成的。调酒师没多看一眼就清理干净了。完全卸下伪装后，我结了晚餐账，上楼睡觉去了。祝大家晚安。
The climb hardly bears mentioning. It was fairly awful-- cold, slippery, kind of arduous, in the middle of an ice storm. Although kind of monochromatically silvery, pale, and glamorous at the top.
爬山过程几乎不值得一提。相当糟糕——寒冷、湿滑、有点艰苦，正处于冰暴之中。虽然在山顶上有一种单色的银色、苍白而迷人的感觉。
A lot of the talk focuses on "1028's." "Think we'll see any 1028's?" "She was a real 1028." "All we need is some 1028's to make this a perfect Christmas." "1028" is code for babes.
许多谈话集中在“1028”上。“你认为我们会看到1028吗？”“她真是一个1028。”“我们只需要一些1028就能让这成为一个完美的圣诞节。”“1028”是美女的代号。
I realize that everything about me-- my inappropriate footwear, my effete lexicon, my unfamiliarity with such natural phenomena as trees, rock, and ice-- are all met with great equanimity and good grace. They're friendly. It becomes quite clear to me that the only one casting strange glances of disapproval my way is me.
我意识到，关于我的一切——我不合适的鞋子、我柔弱的词汇、我对树木、岩石和冰块等自然现象的不熟悉——都得到了极大的平和与善意的对待。他们很友好。我非常清楚地认识到，唯一投以奇怪审视目光 disapproving 的人是我自己。
At the summit, I made Larry take my picture a number of times. When the film comes back, I will look at the photos of myself, scanning them for evidence. Looking for the face of an adult, the face of a man who climbs mountains, the face of a Dave. Thank you.
在山顶，我让拉里拍了好几次我的照片。当胶卷洗出来时，我会看着自己的照片，扫描它们寻找证据。寻找一张成年人的脸，一张爬山的男人的脸，一张“戴夫”的脸。谢谢。
David Rakoff.
大卫·拉科夫。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Our musicians, John Linnell, John Flansburgh, Dan Miller, Dan Hickey, Dan Levine, Danny Weinkauf, and Jim O'Connor. Production help from Emi Takahara, Sylvia Lemus, Chris Ladd, and Todd Bachmann.
好吧，我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己，以及阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克共同制作。我们的音乐家是约翰·林内尔、约翰·弗兰斯伯格、丹·米勒、丹·希基、丹·莱文、丹尼·温考夫和吉姆·奥康纳。制作协助由艾米·高原、西尔维娅·莱姆斯、克里斯·拉德和托德·巴赫曼提供。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Onstage, this show has lasted for an hour and a half. If you want to hear the entire thing, unedited, visit our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. Or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
在舞台上，这场演出持续了一个半小时。如果你想听完整的、未经剪辑的内容，请访问我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org。或者你知道你可以从 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们今天的节目档案。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助者鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who says this to me at least once a week--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他每周至少对我说一次这个——
There is a Canadian consulate nearby.
附近有一家加拿大领事馆。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。